so high my whole nice to meet you what
was thank you for welcoming us here in
welcome to California you will be one of
the speakers at the next conference
title waiting for the barbarians could
you please can't reduce yourself to the
debt challenges yes well so I'm the
publisher skeptic magazine and a monthly
columnist for Scientific American and i
write science books you know related to
believe science and religion science and
pseudoscience science morality science
of God science and politics science and
economics just you know just all
different areas but science is my thing
and you know I'm a college professor I
teach one class in the fall at Chapman
University in Orange County skepticism
101 how to think so these are freshmen
18 year old kids right out of high
school and I their brains are mush and
my job is to mold them into critical
thinkers and then in the spring I
usually teach whatever my next book is
going to be so as a way to write
lectures that become chapters in the
book and that that will just that will
be my next book after the moral arc
which is going to be called Evan's on
earth and it's about the afterlife the
belief in heaven-- the belief and the
perfectibility of human nature utopias
and dystopias heaven and hell you know
that kind of thing you will be on the
second fennel debate which is
how civilized are we what according to
you are the most fundamental pillars of
our civilization well science and reason
is the epistemology that we base most of
our institutions on that is you have to
have evidence and logic and reason for
what you believe and what you want it's
too for social change political change
or whatever so I'm a I think we are the
children of the Enlightenment I macro
enlightenment person and I I think
that's the you know that sort of pillars
of how we build our infrastructure our
social institutions from there of course
democracy constitutional Republic's you
know some sort of basis for the rule of
law and why all people should be treated
equally you know it legally morally and
so on and then economically you know
free trade markets you know the way to
lift people out of poverty is to allow
them to improve their own lives
economically and and then of course just
you know the social institutions that
you know that hold this together whether
that's religion in some countries here
in America and not so much europe by
clearly i use you guys as an example
that the argument that you have to have
religion to be moral yet to have
religion to have a moral society you
have to have religion to have you know
to take care of people is on europeans
are doing very well and better and most
measures in America without religion you
know Europeans were amongst the most
religious people in the world now
they're amongst the least religious
the world and their levels of happiness
oars highest they've ever been you know
people are taking care of universal
health care you know decline the
violence is decline almost no wars so
you've done something right and the idea
that I have is that we should figure out
what that is and do more of it
fundamentalist religion clearly Isis is
the most extreme example but but just in
general then the extremism of any kind
of course it could be Marxist ideology
or something like that but that that's
not a big threat anymore like it was in
the 70s now it's really Islam you know
extreme forms of Islam and you know I
you have to give the disclaimer I don't
mean all Muslims I know most Muslims are
good people and so on but we're talking
about the ones that are not westernized
that don't believe in democracy human
rights they don't think women should be
treated equally and have the same rights
as men they don't you know and so on
that I mean that's that's the biggest
threat to civilization be come along in
a long time I'm confident they won't
succeed but it's not guaranteed I have
to say I hate to say it but sometimes it
takes boots on the ground it takes
military action I mean some people you
can reason with some people you cannot
reason with and you know al Qaeda
Islamic terrorism Hamas Isis and so on
but you know they want to return the
world to a 7th century theocracy this is
not going to happen and if it takes you
know troops and hardware if it takes
bombs and guns that's what it's going to
take and I fear that is what it's going
to take
I'd rather it not be I'd rather you know
I'm a man of books and literature and
reason and teaching and education if we
could do it with that that would be my
preference unfortunately they don't seem
to make responding to bed